welcome to the heavy spurlie show i'm
your host paul aka [ __ ] grayson
and we have a whole host of new batman
images to talk about that have been
popping up online all week
throughout this video we're going to be
going through all the new picks
and discussing our thoughts and theories
on them there might be some spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day
and drop a thumbs up yeah cause because
you're a good guy now without the way
thank you for clicking this let's get
into the breakdown okay so there's
pretty much three things being shot at
the same time right now in liverpool
england
this includes the exterior of the
courthouse the bike chase
and also a batman glider scene that
we'll talk about in just a bit
i'm guessing that after production was
shut down due to kovid
they didn't want to lose any time at all
and thus they've made sure they can make
as much of the movie as possible
in a shorter space of time as they can
movies do tend to overlap when shooting
but to have all this going on at once is
a pretty big feat for anyone who's
running the schedule on these things
so props to the creative team for
getting so much done so quickly
now the first image we need to talk
about is related to the bike chase
between batman and selena kyle
presumably after she's just stolen
something from the mayor's office
when the stunt double was walking around
eagle-eyed fans noticed what looked like
a gun on the side of the flying scouse
mouse's leg
however liverpool fans need to calm down
calm down
because this is most likely the grapnel
gun that we saw the character using in
the trailer
i'm sorry for doing that played out
liverpool joke by the way
you know i love you now you might
remember that we actually
theorized that batman's grappling gun
would be made out of a modified handgun
and this seems to lean heavily into that
this is because we also saw that he had
bullet clip pouches on his belt
and shout outs to big bat theory for
going over this with us
as it looks like it could indeed be
correct from what we've seen of the
chase scene
everyone's falling over themselves to
get a shot of it and it looks like it's
gonna be one of the big action set
pieces of the movie
so i'm really really hyped for it cut to
the funeral scene
and we have what seems to be bruce wayne
confronting the penguin over something
we have theorized that he will be
running for may in light of the x1's
death
and obviously this spell is doomed for
bruce as it will lead to more corruption
in the city that he's trying to clean up
clearly bruce isn't thinking of the
ramifications of confronting a mob boss
like this in broad daylight
i think this is because he hasn't really
created his persona yet
you might remember that bruce did a
similar thing to falcone and batman
begins
and this was pretty much the meeting
that sparked up the idea he had to go
and build his secret identity as the
batman
now speaking of falcone we got a lot of
shots of him
selena kyle and what could also be a new
cast member in the family now in the
long halloween which this movie is
reportedly based upon
it turned out that selena was searching
for the identity of her father
and she had suspicions that this was
actually falcone
the character ended up getting her own
spin-off book called when in rome
in which she went looking for clues to
this and found it to be true
however it appears that the movie is
skipping that part and there has been
some reports stating that she's already
well aware that she is falcone's
daughter
and will be secretly working against him
kindly getting a lot of huntress vibes
from this storyline
and mystery of the batwoman which does
have similar plot elements in it
on top of this i think selena looks
absolutely fantastic
and it's such a brilliant recreation of
her look in the long halloween
shout outs to batman curator on twitter
for putting this collage together
and you can really see how everything
lines up side by side
to show that they are paying respect to
the source material i know you already
know that because of the design of the
batsuit
but i think they're just completely
nailing everything here
battens and batman also made a great set
of side-by-side images
that show how much attention to detail
everything has and we can really see
that they've got it done pat
in sun now falcone and penguin i think
will be bitter rivals in this movie
and though the latter doesn't really
feature too much in the long halloween
the former does and he pretty much runs
the city his family and friends are
taken out one by one by a killer known
as holliday
who's revealed at the end of the book to
be his son alberto falcone
you might remember that gil perez
abraham was cast in the film
and as of now we don't know who he is
completely but i do think that he will
be the infamous mob boss's son
i think it would be brilliant if both
carmine's children were working against
him
but i don't know if they'll have time to
bring alberto in with just how packed
everything currently is
now at the courthouse we've also spotted
members of what's being called the
riddler gang
the internet is currently going back and
forth over whether they're working with
him or not
personally i don't really think they are
i think the movie will likely do
something similar to joker
and have people in the city inspired by
what they see as a vigilante
and that they will start it on similar
attire to him in order to show that
they're just sick of how corrupt gotham
is they even put up some
some lovely signs saying our day of
judgment along with lies lies lies
which of course ties back to the no more
lies thing that was written on the
mayor's face above the tape
now i can't verify this but according to
yes infinite who said they were at the
scene
the gang was shouting law and order
which
i t i tell you if batman's bloody gone
woke i'll kill him
again we can't verify this for definite
but with everything that's going on
it does make sense that they would try
and jam something in like that
just to add a bit more social commentary
to the movie
at the scene we also got hints that
there might be other villains operating
in the city
if you cast our mind back to our
previous coverage you might recall that
we theorized that barry keown was
actually playing the mad hatter
and his casting as stanley merkel was a
bit of a ruse to throw us off the scent
now whether or not this is true it does
look like there's another villain
operating in gotham
that we haven't actually had confirmed
yet at the set there were gotham health
warnings but up to stop people from
taking something
known as drops now this could be a
number of villains from the scarecrow to
the joker or mad hatter himself
i know the latter tends to use hats to
control people but if you recall in our
theory breakdown video
big bat theory stated that they thought
he might just be a drug pusher
it could be possible that merkel due to
his ability to get
access to the evidence room in the
police station is taking things like
joggers toxin
and then selling them off at street
level under the guise the mad hatter
again this is all just theorizing but it
would be a brilliant way to bring the
villain in
whilst also hinting at the larger
universe such as the joker and scarecrow
it looks like we aren't the only people
diving into batman's stuff either
as at the liver building onlookers
caught a glimpse of a stunned double
wearing a glider costume
while standing on the edge of it now as
we know
this batman is very diy so it does make
sense that he wouldn't
actually have the glide function built
into his cape and would instead donna
sue or something like this
should he need to get into a specific
sealed off area unfortunately i couldn't
find any footage of the character
actually gliding
but i'm guessing this will be another
big scene in the film similar to the one
in the dark knight
again batman curated put together a
brilliant side-by-side image of this
moment
that i think really captures just how
much effort the production team are
putting in
to make sure everything is right and
true to the source material
and finally i was searching for towers
and locations for the film
and came across this from bc eu which
after researching further i believe
could be true
in the tweet the account says that they
believe chicago's tribune tower
will become wayne tower in the movie
i've actually heard a lot of theories
floating around about this
and though i can't confirm it yet i have
a pretty strong feeling that it might
well be
if this theory is correct then i can see
this sort of being a penthouse set up
similar to what bruce had in the dark
knight
and who knows they may even connect the
gliding from the liver building to this
in order to make one seamless shot we've
seen with the funeral scene how the
exterior of the courthouse looks nothing
like the interior of the cathedral
but with a bit of movie magic they
brought it all together
another meant to be filming in chicago
this weekend so hopefully we get some
confirmation of this serie
so you guys can say you son of a [ __ ]
you did it again
and and by did it again i mean the first
rumor that i've
ever gotten right now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on this video and
if you enjoyed it you should probably be
hitting that thumbs up button right now
what what do you mean you've already
done it wow
you're the real hero gotham deserves now
but we appreciate it
and if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the prior images outside
the courthouse which are going to be
linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can always come chatters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavyspoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul
i'll see you next time take care peace
you